question stimuler les sens c'est selon
les professionnels la manière la plus
efficace de retarder les effets des
pathologies liées au vieillissement dans
cette maison de retraite spécialisée
des activités sont proposées plusieurs
fois par semaine quelques-uns des
résidences sont atteints de la maladie
d'alzheimer
l'enjeu est de trouver les stratégies
pour ralentir l'évolution mais il faut
aussi prévenir l'apparition de la
maladie chez ceux qui ne présentent pas
de signe ça fait en mai jamais soigné
leur autonomie parce que vous avez bien
vu ce en train de participer à l'atelier
ont fait un sens aux rapports en
intégrant les ingrédients cette activité
son activité culinaire et ça permet une
activité très complète
parce qu'en fait on a là l'aspect
sensoriel avec le toucher
le bout également l'odorat et la
motricité la motricité fine c'est à dire
en utilisant les les ustensiles exemple
un citron de prendre un citron c'est la
motricité fine toutes ces pathologies
sont inscrits dans le fameux plan
maladies neurodégénératives 2014 2019 il
s'appuie sur une centaine de mesures une
des priorités améliorer la prise en
charge des malades et des aidants les
familles à tout moment peuvent nous
intervenons soie ivoire le médecin
traitant qui travaille avec munitie soit
il voit le médecin coordonnateur
ou alors ils ont la possibilité aussi
d'être accompagné par la psychologue
parmi les outils préconisés il y a les
maisons d'accueil pour soulager
non seulement les aidons mais aussi leur
portefeuille et un budget global ou une
partie est prise en charge la partie
soins par les services de l'état la rs
et la partie dépendant cependant la ctm
il y a un petit reste à change qui le 5
50 euros qui correspond à peu près à
moins de 6 euros de l'heure environ 6
euros de l'heure
donc c'est très accessible la rs en
charge de ce plan n'a pas répondu à
notre demande d'entretien mais il faut
savoir que le plan prévoit 65 nouvelle
plateforme d'accompagnement et de répit
pour la france et d outre-mer
cela semble insuffisant par kingson
sclérose en plaques alzheimer sont les
maladies neurodégénératives les plus
répandus en france le nombre de
personnes atteintes est estimé à près
d'un million